just bring you a bit of breaking news  concerning nhs pay  you might remember uh the uk government  has offered one per cent pay to  nurses amongst others and nicolas  sturgeon has just intervened on that for  scottish staff saying our nhs staff  deserve more than applause  and one percent is not enough uh the  scottish government is offering a  four percent pay rise which would  deliver guaranteed minimum  increases of a thousand pounds for those  earning less than twenty five thousand  pounds  and a five 5.4 increase for staff on the  lowest pay band  all backdated she says to december 2020  so once again  separating herself and scotland from the  rest of the uk we will get reaction to  that story  as the program progresses